[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'histoire d'un petit château
mignon qui propose à ses amis chat un
jeu les règles du jeu sont les suivantes
le petit château mignon on va l'appeler
albert fournit une pièce de 50 cents aux
joueurs qui la lance en l'air
si le joueur fait pile il gagne la pièce
de monnaie
mais si le joueur fait face le piège
commencent à se refermer sur lui il doit
alors placé une pièce d'un euro sur la
table et s'il veut la récupérer et
gagner les 50 cents il faut qu'ils
obtiennent pile lors d'un second lancer
si jamais il n'y arrive pas il doit
alors placé une pièce de deux euros sur
la table
et s'il veut la récupérer et quand même
gagné les 50 cents il faut qu'ils
obtiennent pile lors d'un ultime lancer
s'il n'y arrive pas il a tout perdu
la seule manière qu'il a de s'en sortir
cette sphère pile sur le troisième
lancer à partir d'ici il faudrait être
fou pour jouer à ce jeu non on risque de
perdre au total 3 euros pour gagner une
minable pièce de 50 cents
esch des candidats dans l'audience pour
ce jeu lever la main qui parmi vous
accepterait de jouer au jeu d'albert non
personne
presque personne bon c'est pas grave on
va essayer un autre jeu je vous présente
l'une des cartes à gratter les plus
populaires du pays
et comme je ne veux pas qu'on m'accuse
en faire trop de publicité j'ai
volontairement flouté à l'image le nom
de la carte
le principe de cette carte il est très
simple pour la modique somme de 3 euros
vous avez une chance de gagner 2000
euros par mois à vie
ce pas trop mal non qui parmi vous
préférerait jouer à ce jeu aussi plutôt
qu'aux jeux d'albert
si on vous force à choisir entre l'un
des deux jeux qui parmi vous préférez
jouer au jeu de la carte à gratter lever
la main et là on a beaucoup plus de gens
presque tout le monde votre choix il a
été guidé par quelque chose de très
simple
dans les deux jeux on risque au pire de
perdre la somme de 3 euros
mais dans le cas du jeu de la carte à
gratter ce que l'on peut potentiellement
gagner fait rêver tandis que albert avec
sa petite pièce de 50 cents
il fait pas vraiment rêver je veux dire
si je gagne le jeu d'albert je n'ai même
pas assez pour m'acheter une canette au
distributeur local
pourtant si votre but c'est
l'enrichissement personnel au travers
des jeux de hasard c'est bien au jeu
d'albert qu'il aurait fallu jouer pas
tellement parce que la probabilité de
perdre à son jeu n'est que de 1 8e c'est
la probabilité de faire trois faces
d'affilée ce n'est pas vraiment ça la
raison pour laquelle il faut jouer au
jeu d'albert mais bien parce que le
bilan mathématique du jeu est positif
les statisticiens appel ce bilan
l'espérance du jeu comment ça marchait
très simple il suffit de prendre chaque
probabilités et de la multiplier par le
gain correspondant positifs ou négatifs
et d'additionner tous les résultats
ce qui nous donne plus 0,0625 euros en
stats il existe un truc très puissant
qui s'appelle la loi des grands nombres
en une phrase ce que la loi des grands
nombres nous dit ceci si vous jouez un
très grand nombre de fois un jeu de
hasard votre bien à chaque partie pourra
être approximer par l'espérance du jeu
en clair si je joue mille fois aux jeux
d'albert je suis garantie par la loi des
grands nombres de me retrouver avec
environ 1000 fois l'espérance c'est à
dire plus de 62 euros et l'espérance de
la carte à gratter alors si on regarde
le dos de la carte et qu'on a grandi la
partie inférieure de la carte on voit
qu'il ya une chance sur un million de
gagner 2000 euros par mois à vie mais il
ya aussi 15 chance de gagner le montant
fixe de 2500 euros
il ya cinquante chance de gagner 250
euros et il ya même une chance sur dix
de gagner 6 euros avant de pouvoir
calculer l'espérance de cette carte
il faut que je transforme la deuxième
colonne de ce tableau en une colonne de
probabilité
voici le résultat j'ai simplement été
divisées chaque valeur par un million
deuxièmement il faut pas oublier que
cette carte n'est pas gratuite elle
coûte 3 euros
et donc il faut que j'aille soustraire
se montrent
à chacun des gains potentiels ce qui va
donner ceci
ensuite on sera pas forcément dans l'un
des cas de figure situé à l'écran on va
également très souvent en fait juste
perdre la somme de 3 euros
ça va arriver 75% du temps dernière
chose qu'il faut que je fasse
il faut que je m'inquiète de ce que 2000
euros par mois à vie représente vraiment
assez difficile à estimer mais pour un
gagnant de 40 ans qui va vivre jusqu'à
disons 80 ans
cela représente et bien 2000 euros x 12
mois x 40 années ce qui fait neuf cent
soixante mille euros auxquels soyons
rigoureux
il ne faut pas oublier d'aller
soustraire le prix de la carte 3 euros
nous sommes prêts pour le calcul de
l'espérance de cette carte on multiplie
chacune des probabilités par le gain
correspondant positifs ou négatifs et on
sommes tous les résultats
voici ce que ça donne moins 78 cents
conceptuellement cela veut dire que
chaque carte à gratter fait perdre aux
joueurs 78 cents
on peut même calculé que pour un lot
d'un million de cartes
cela correspondra une perte cumulée pour
tous les joueurs de 780 mille euros mais
avant de déchirer avec rage la carte et
de vous dire je le savais ce sont tous
des pourris
j'aimerais vous inviter à réfléchir au
delà de ces nombres il faut savoir qu'en
belgique
le profit généré par cette carte en
particulier est presque entièrement
reversés pour des projets culturels
sportifs scientifiques et même
humanitaire ne vous demandez pas en tant
que joueur
si un jeu de hasard est désavantageux
pour vous évidemment que les jeux de
hasard sont désavantageux pour vous tous
les jeux de hasard le son ne soyez pas
naïfs mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
ne pas jouer aux jeux de hasard fait
plutôt comme albert posez vous la
question de ce qui va être fait avec
votre argent
et si jamais la réponse ne vous
satisfait pas alors trouver une autre
manière de vous divertir
j'espère que ce tome vous a plu les
illustrations sont de laura mme aubry
[Applaudissements]